وصلت الأنقاض في العاصمة السودانية الخرطوم إلى
نقطة الانهيار، وهذا وفقًا لمنظمة إنقاذ
الأطفال، حيث تقول المنظمة الإنسانية إن آلاف
الجثث تُركت ببساطة في
الشوارع، وتقول المنظمة الإنسانية إن
مزيجًا مرعبًا من
الأعداد المتزايدة من الجثث، ونقصًا حادًا في المياه، وتعطل
خدمات النظافة والصرف الصحي.  كما أن نقص
خيارات معالجة المياه يثير
مخاوف من تفشي مرض الكوليرا في المدينة، حيث
يقاتل الجيش السوداني والقوات شبه العسكرية قوات الدعم السريع من أجل السيطرة
على الكارتون منذ ما يقرب من أربعة أشهر حتى الآن، لذا
دعونا نحضر لاري مادوو الخاص بنا
للحصول على أحدث الأخبار.  لاري، ما هي
حالة البنية التحتية
والخدمات العامة المتاحة للناس في
السودان في الوقت الحالي؟ بيانكا:
ظل هذا الصراع محتدمًا منذ
حوالي 115 يومًا، وانهارت
البنية التحتية للصحة والصرف الصحي تقريبًا،
ولهذا السبب تسمع هذه
المنظمات الثماني تحذر من
احتمال تفشي الكوليرا، أريد أن أقرأ
لكم مقطعًا من هذا اليوم
لتحذير الأطفال يقول
مزيجًا مرعبًا من الأعداد المتزايدة
من الجثث، ونقصًا حادًا في المياه،
وعدم كفاءة خدمات النظافة والصرف الصحي، كما أن
الافتقار إلى خيارات معالجة المياه
يثير المخاوف أيضًا  من
تفشي وباء الكوليرا، هذه ليست سوى
الأحدث في مجموعة واسعة من المشاكل التي
تواجهها مدينة الخرطوم على وجه الخصوص، حيث
أخبرني الناس أنهم ليس لديهم
كهرباء أو أنهم يعانون من
نقص طويل في الوقود في عصرنا هذا
فقط  مما يتفاقم مع جميع
المشاكل الأخرى التي يواجهونها عندما تكون في
الحرب لمدة أربعة أشهر تقريبًا وقد اختفى أي
مبدأ أساسي لوظيفة ما في المجتمع لاري،
ما هو الأحدث في الصراع
وأي محاولات لحله ما
زلنا  نسمع حتى اليوم عن
قتال عنيف في أم درمان في
شمال الخرطوم، ولا يزال هذا في
جوهره معركة من أجل السيطرة
بين القوات المسلحة السودانية وقوات
الدعم السريع، هذه
المجموعة شبه العسكرية القوية التي نشأت من
جانجا مع الميليشيات وهكذا  لقد تراجع هذا الصراع
عن اهتمام العالم نوعًا ما،
حيث استحوذت النيجر على الكثير من
هذا الاهتمام، لكنه لم يقترب من
الاكتمال حتى الآن، وقد نزح أكثر من 4.2 مليون
شخص من
منازلهم، 70 منهم جوستين هارتوم وحده،
وهذا يعني أن واحدًا في كل عام  اضطر 10 أشخاص في
السودان إلى مغادرة منازلهم،
وعبر ما يقرب من مليون شخص إلى
البلدان المجاورة مثل مصر
وتشاد وجنوب السودان في محاولة للهروب
من هذا الصراع الذي لن يختفي في
أي وقت قريب، وكانت هناك
الكثير من جهود الوساطة.
الجهود التي بذلتها المملكة العربية السعودية والولايات المتحدة
لإجراء محادثات في جدة لمحاولة جمع
هذه الفصائل المتحاربة معًا، كانت لها
نتائج مختلطة، حيث اتفقوا على بعض
وقف إطلاق النار الذي لم يدم طويلاً، وهناك
محاولة أخرى في 25 أغسطس، قام بها
الاتحاد الأفريقي والهيئة
الحكومية الدولية.  جلبت
هذه الأطراف إلى جولة أخرى من المحادثات
في أديس أبابا في إثيوبيا، والناس
لا يحبسون أنفاسهم لأنه حتى الآن نجح
نان في تحقيق أي سلام طويل الأمد.